gira diplomática por Estados Unidos el
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
habló el miércoles en la sede de la
Organización de Estados Americanos en
Washington hizo un llamado regional que
es una lucha de toda la humanidad por
traerla como una democracia muchísimo
más profunda que la antigua democracia
representativa y liberal sin negarla
América Latina puede ser El Vocero
mundial de ese nuevo proyecto
democrático
Petro también repasó otros asuntos de
interés latinoamericano volvió a
criticar a Perú por la prisión
preventiva en la que se encuentra Pedro
castillo y al proponer una reescritura
de la carta democrática habló de Cuba y
Venezuela Claro que sí me interesa Y lo
estoy luchando que Venezuela
reingrese al sistema interamericano de
Derechos Humanos
Claro que deberíamos conversarlo con
Cuba precisamente el viaje por Estados
Unidos tiene a Venezuela en el centro la
gira culmina con una reunión bilateral
en la casa blanca con Joe biden
presidente de Estados Unidos
Petro va a pedir que levanten las
sanciones contra el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro la Casa Blanca dijo estar
dispuesta a un alivio de los castigos
pero solo si el país sudamericano da
pasos concretos hacia unas elecciones
libres la retoma de relaciones con
Venezuela y el retorno de su vecino a la
Esfera internacional ha sido una de las
prioridades de Petro desde que llegó a
la presidencia el 7 de agosto tras la
reunión con biden el martes 25 de abril
será el turno en Bogotá de una
conferencia internacional sobre
Venezuela con cancilleres de todo el
mundo y con la incógnita de la presencia
de Nicolás maduro